[Musica]
det
Ok
Buonasera
eh Ecco
eh
non non riesco a
respirare un attimo di cuore eh
bloccato le le gambe tremano
e il mio corpo è un muro un
blocco non vi sento ho
paura Ma se io
invece decidessi
di
arrivare
presente prendere l'emozione normale che
c'è la paura e decidessi di respirarci
dentro tornare
consapevole i miei piedi radicati qui ed
ora sentire di nuovo questo corpo che
non è più
ah un muro un blocco tra me e come io
sto e voi ma torna ad essere uno
strumento un mezzo di
comunicazione ok Molto meglio Sono
pronta Tranquilli
tranquilli Ecco io direi che oggi vorrei
proprio parlare di
questo che è quello che ha cambiato
completamente la mia esistenza l'unica
eredità che io possa lasciare su questo
palcoscenico è la mia verità e dunque
aver scoperto di avere uno strumento di
essere stata dotata di uno strumento e
quindi io mi sono scoperta a un certo
punto
musicista e quindi anche voi anche voi
siete musicisti Cioè qui un violinista
un trombonista clarinetto giusto
traverso ognuno di noi con il nostro
strumento diverso siamo tutti musicisti
siamo musicisti quindi ciao musicisti
Come state siete accordati avete
accordato lo
strumento No perché è evidente che un
violinista non andrebbe mai a suonare
nell'orchestra con un violino scordato
questo è evidente No ma voi l'avete
accordato il vostro strumento Stamattina
vi siete presi la responsabilità di
ascoltare e di sapere come sto rispetto
alle mie emozioni al mio corpo alla mia
mente perché questo strumento questo
strumento corpo di cui siamo stati
dotati è esattamente l'eredità la
responsabilità e l'unico modo che
abbiamo per
creare una società in
armonia come se ognuno dei nostri
strumenti creasse la possibilità di
armonia oppure di
perché l'opposto di uno strumento
accordato è uno strumento in
dissenso tre cani dà la definizione di
accordare Come ridurre a giusta
intonazione uno strumento musicale
armonizzare le varie parti di uno
strumento corpo mente ed
emozioni Dunque abbiamo questa
responsabilità qui il nostro strumento
accordato nel qui e nell'ora altrimenti
io rischio di perdermi questa esistenza
perché perché sarò intrappolata nella
mia testa chiusa in questa scatola mente
pensando che sia l'unico modo di fare
esperienza vita quindi quando vedo una
persona per strada che dice no oggi come
stai Sto un po' così mi sento un po'
così un po' una merda mi sento benissimo
eh
Eh si vede che c'ho i pensieri Eh c'ho i
pensieri mi sento un po' triste ma
magari è stata la peperonata che te sei
magnato ieri perché questo strumento
corpo funziona così è un accordo
bidirezionale tra mente e corpo
emozioni Si parlava di eredità tutto
quello che rimane all'interno del nostro
corpo è un'eredità generazionale che c'è
stata tramandata ma ne siamo
consapevoli da attrice mi è stato
evidente fin dall'inizio di questo
strumento corpo di il potere che io
avessi a
disposizione nel sentire delle cose
vivere delle cose o semplicemente far
finta chiedevo al mio corpo un esercizio
dell'aor studio ci richiedeva di
riproporre al nostro corpo attraverso la
memoria emotiva la sensazione di avere
una tazza calda di tè tra le mani e
bisognava semplicemente stare lì con gli
occhi chiusi respirare e immaginare di
avere questa tazza di tè caldo provatelo
a casa improvvisamente si sente il caldo
tra le dita e se chiudiamo gli occhi
Davvero E ci immergiamo nel momento
presente sentiamo anche il profumo di tè
un sorso di tè e sentiamo il sapore del
tè Questo è il potere del nostro
strumento corpo quindi noi abbiamo una
possibilità di camminare attraverso la
nostra esistenza
vedendo un
albero
oppure ci
radichi
respiriamo ci rendiamo conto che c'è
questo meraviglioso ondeggiare come se
fossero proprio delle Vibrazioni e ci
rendiamo conto che la nostra vibrazione
corpo entra in sintonia con la
vibrazione di questo meraviglioso albero
e improvvisamente ente non è solo più un
albero ma è
un'orchestra orchestra di radice
orchestra di albero orchestra di di sole
di vento ed io vibro insieme a
quest'albero e la nostra esistenza
potrebbe diventare così sapete perché
noi siamo vibrazioni
37.200 miliardi di cellule all'interno
del nostro corpo vibrano costantemente
per comunicare e non tutte le
comunicazioni sono uguali ci sono delle
comunicazioni che parlano di
tra cellule e cellule sono comunicazioni
completamente diverse e poi ci sono
comunicazioni armoniche che parlano di
aggiustiamo questa
ferita oggetti animati oggetti inanimati
sono vibrazione e il modo più semplice
che abbiamo chiaramente è ascoltare la
musica Quella è la vibrazione immediata
che ci arriva sappiamo di mucche a cui
viene proposto la musica di Mozart per
creare più latte topi Ratti a cui è
stato trapiantato trapiantati che
attraverso una musica armonica riescono
a sopravvivere du mesi in
più il potere della vibrazione esiste
perché ha un effetto su di noi perché
noi siamo vibrazione Dunque questo
strumento corpo come lo
suoniamo siamo accordati ne siamo
consapevoli Intanto come sto dunque la
domanda di come sto che è la domanda con
cui abbiamo iniziato oggi quello che io
mi aspetterei da voi è questa risposta
come sto Sento un'emozione nel tratto
del plesso solare che mi spinge giù è la
paura poi c'ho qui tutta la tensione di
tutte le cose che non ho detto a mio
marito sulla spalla destra c'ho la
mascella che mi fa male sento proprio
qui tutti i muscoli aggrovigliati dalle
cose non dette un blocco nel petto Ecco
questo è uno strumento che torna ad
essere
consapevole e la consapevolezza è il
modo in cui noi Formiamo il nostro
futuro come gli animali siamo
programmati per rispondere agli stimoli
ambientali in modo integrato corpo mente
ed emozioni
Quindi io Vi propongo di tornare ad
essere accordati insieme a me e quello
che faremo tutti insieme è come un
direttore d'orchestra
accorda la propria orchestra entra il
direttore fa il
è il là questa nota che accorda ogni
strumento tutti strumenti diversi che
però con una nota solo si
accordano ci accordiamo anche tutti noi
insieme se siete
d'accordo abbiamo detto che abbiamo la
responsabilità di essere consapevole di
come sta il nostro strumento corpo e una
volta che lo sappiamo di accordarci Ecco
un'altra definizione di accordo è dalla
Repubblica dove ci
accordiamo alla sorgente è come se ci
accordasse in un orchestra è il là per
noi sarà il suono da cui tutta il mondo
è partito l'origine del nostro creato
ovvero l'om no dicono che c'è questo
suono che ha creato il nostro universo
il suono e l'om quindi oggi ci diamo la
possibilità di accordare i nostri
strumenti con l'origine dell'universo
con la speranza che questo accordo ci
possa
riaccedere tutti insieme adesso è di
fare un bella una
ispirazione dal
naso espirare dalla bocca fatelo provate
ne facciamo tre di respiri
ancora inspiriamo portiamo l'aria
all'interno della nostra pancia questa
cassa di risonanza ed espiriamo
espirando Magari andiamo a chiudere gli
occhi andiamo a rilasciare le tensioni a
connetterci con la terra la pianta
pianta del piede da cui escono delle
radici che ci riconnettono alla Terra
Non a caso si chiama pianta Non a caso
inspiro
e e torno qui presente all'interno del
mio strumento corpo e poi andremo a
prendere un altro respiro profondo e
faremo un Home tutti insieme occhi
chiusi e sentiremo le vibrazioni nostre
e dei nostri vicini
[Musica]
inspiro
ancora
[Musica]
inspiro
l'ultimo
Ascolto le
vibrazioni Uniti di
nuovo
all'universo in accordo tra di noi
grazie